in our series i on earth we're looking
at what may be the future of farming on
a very changing planet
from 2001 to 2016 the us lost
11 million acres of farmland mostly to
development
so that translates to one and a half
acres every minute across the u.s
only 19 percent of land is considered
best for growing foods and crops
cbs news senior environmental
correspondent that's ben tracy
traveled to kentucky to meet a
pioneering young farmer who's also
giving his
appalachian community an economic boost
we build big this rectangle of steel and
glass
stretches for nearly half a mile and
just as you start to take it all
in you realize that's only the half of
it
when we do something we put our mind to
it we go massive
jonathan webb used to build solar energy
projects for the government
it's like surfing coming down here now
the 35 year old is running one of the
largest indoor farming operations
in the world growing row after row
after row of tomatoes this greenhouse is
the size of 58 football fields
so big you can't see where it ends do
you think of yourself as a farmer
yeah this is farming calling it app
harvest
isn't just clever tech talk it's located
in appalachia
just outside morehead kentucky everybody
watch out for central appalachia
we are absolutely going to be one of the
largest fruit and vegetable suppliers of
the u.s
in the decades to come climate change is
not only altering our weather patterns
but it's changing where and how we grow
our food
a lot of our produce comes from
california and mexico
two places now hit with frequent and
devastating droughts
kentucky is getting wetter and has
location
on its side we can get to 70 percent of
the us in a one-day drive
whereas right now you're importing
product from mexico
coming two weeks on a truck app harvest
plans to build at least a dozen of these
indoor grow facilities
they use rain water collected on the
massive roof and stored in this pond
the size of 70 olympic swimming pools
water is delivered to the plants in
precise amounts so it isn't wasted
once that rain water is in here it only
leaves as a tomato
they can grow year round and all night
when the greenhouse shows its more
colorful side
thanks to special grow lights that keep
the 720
thousand plants inside reaching for the
sky
the company says farming this way uses
90 percent
less water no soil and results in 30
times more yield per acre
than a regular outdoor farm so you may
be thinking well that's great for
tomatoes but i'd like to eat more than
just tomatoes well they say they can do
this for any sort of vine crop
including cucumbers bell peppers and
berries
there are downsides building huge
structures of steel and glass creates
its own planet
warming emissions and it takes energy to
run all those nighttime lights
the tomatoes also cost a bit more than
the ones grown in mexico
but reinventing farming on a changing
planet is crucial
because the united nations says the
world's farmers need to grow
60 percent more food by 2050 to feed the
estimated
9.3 billion people that will be living
on the planet
this is 30 years away we're not talking
like great grandkids need to figure
this out we're talking we need to figure
this out
webb has big backers and sitting on his
board of directors
is a legend the food world knows by just
one name
and i was terrified is martha going to
like this tomato
so martha stewart we got her a box
martha calls these are fabulous they're
wonderful she posted them on instagram
and that was the that was the moment we
knew we had a winner how we doing
but for webb this hits home he's from
central
appalachia an area hit hard by the
collapse of tobacco and coal
where one in three people live below the
poverty line
you know we shut down the coal mines and
no one said what's next
app harvest has greeted more than 500
jobs at this one facility
the company has also given stock options
to its employees
there are people in tears
people have never owned a car never in
the house
at the top of the vines we met up with
sam smith who used to harvest
a much different crop tobacco when that
came to a halt so
the money so it's hard to find you know
good consistent work like this
you know it's a blessing you got it webb
believes he
and his orange army are building a new
future for appalachia
it's a runaway freight train now it's a
matter how big is it going to be
how fast are we going to go and that's
saying something
given how big it already is for cbs this
morning ben tracy
morehead kenducky this is jonathan webb
i had no idea what's going on and it
makes so much sense when you think about
it yeah
yeah but what a brain he has yes oh my
gosh i like him
tomatoes cucumbers peppers and berries
all growable and those kinds of things i
like how ben did the piece because i was
wondering is there anything more than
tomatoes and then he adds that i also
like that
jonathan was worried about what martha
was going to say because if she didn't
like it she would say that too i tell
you what i got my martha stewart
grilling book out just the other day
just because summer's coming and i
wanted to refresh
and those are those are some
good-looking tomatoes yeah they are i
was talking a lot about salads who knows
and jonathan webb 35. hey